I as a young actor you know I was like
watching dairo and Pacino and Dustin
Hoffman and Warren batty and Jack Lemon
and those are your guys well yeah I mean
that's what you looked up to you aspired
to be yeah especially dairo you know
Taxi Driver changed my life tax the
movie Taxi Driver turned me into a
different turned me into I want to be
like that guy I want to be like that guy
just because of the raw it's it's a
movie it's it's the best of the best as
far as I scor say you go he didn't win
the Academy Award for that but he it the
score the the Jody
Foster but dairo in it is just
stunningly brilliant were you
intimidated by his performance or like
no I want to do that I I want to do that
I wasn't intimidated by I know I really
don't get intimidated by anybody you
know there's not one actor that you go
God man I I can't do what he does
oh there's a lot of actors that that
that I can't do what they do but if I'm
I never claimed to do that so you know
I'm not intimidated I'm just like okay
well I'm me so um I can do this and
that's you know that's what I do so I
met dairo once because he used to stay
at the Mayflower Hotel in New York City
which is no longer there and I was there
with my uh wife at the time or
girlfriend wife my first wife and uh
where I was at a restaurant and I was
sitting there and I was like [__]
Robert Dao's oh my God it's Robert daero
Robert Dao honey that's Robert daero
sitting over there you know and I was
like you know and uh dairo looks up and
uh he looks over at my my table he looks
over at me and he goes like this come on
come on over here what I like what I
said H that's had you done anything at
this point uh yeah I was doing the fan
okay I was shooting the fan at the time
and he stay he I think he had like a
permanent place at the Mayflower Hotel
and I was staying at the Mayflower Hotel
and and but I hadn't seen him around the
Hotel this the
first that's exact that's exactly what
yeah yeah very good yeah very good and
uh I was like oh my God you know what
you know what
couldt what could he possibly say to me
I went over there and he was with like a
little a little group and uh two or
three guys and he said uh that that girl
you knew can't I I can't do I can't do
Impressions who's that girl yeah yeah
yeah is that your sister he
says I'm I'm like uh no Bobby no uh no I
said no Mr dairo that's that's my wife
and uh oh I get the [__] back exactly
that was my experience and then my then
my wife ended up setting him up with one
of her girlfriends and he went out with
one of her girlfriends who was from New
York and that didn't go very well but
you didn't hang out with him after that
really no no I've never seen him again